okay for people
joining this live stream we are starting
to look at some functionality for the
upcoming version of language there's
always an upcoming version
but as they get closer we look more
intensely
there will be a whole bunch of these
design reviews coming in the next week
or two
this is our very first one and it is on
the subject of calculus and algebra
back to uh some of our
earliest killer
features all right start off
special functions fox h is this the our
first
is this the first time we've had fox h i
thought we'd had fox h before
i know wow but people have been
people have been militating for fox h
for years
that's right and now we're gonna get it
who was fox anyway charles fox he was uh
i think he wasn't the biggest
contributor to fox 8 actually
i think that the precursor to all of
this is um
melon and barnes so y'all marmellin or
meline
he's uh hannah hanna svensk he's swedish
swedish finnish and then barnes is a
british guy who became a
big wheel in the uh uk church
so he left academia but they studied
something called melan barnes
representations
that are basically these kinds of
integral of gamma functions that you see
there
yep and mayer g which was introduced in
version three
of mathematica is
is just slightly simpler than this if
you look at those
gamma functions there what's new here
are all those
alphas and betas those are just one in
the case of
uh of mayer g
wow and that's taken 25 years so this is
getting closer
to complete melon barns everything that
melon bars can represent
why are we showing off with some weird
thing here we shouldn't do that
no it's not final sorry
okay we won't well we're going full
swedish here with metallic lefleur as
well
yeah mitta leffler is uh is the um
actually the advisor of yala mermelin
and mittak leflow was a phd student of
by carl beyerstrasz okay
and he's the reason why there is no
nobel prize in mathematics
i know that story yes i know that
is that story true or is that i don't
know it's probably not
probably just a good story
okay so basically i mean this thing is
it's kind of a useful representation
justice mayor g has been a very useful
representation
for doing like definite integration
because
when you have products of things it
becomes a type of convolution in this
space and it becomes very easy to do the
integrals
um so this generalizes this so this
extends the scope
what can be integrated it's heavily used
in probability and statistics for
distributions that's one area
where people have gone through all the
trouble of
so what's the characteristic integral
that can be done with this
it's sort of products of things products
of of hypergeometrics
i see okay cool
anything we should look at with respect
to this it seems like it's a fairly
straight shot
yeah so this is we want to introduce
this as experimental
because we are not entirely sure that
we'll get all the evaluation
and all the support in in time for 12 3.
and then we expect to unexperimentalize
it in 13.
okay
carlson elliptic integral functions
that's a lot of functions that's right
okay should i pick a random one yeah
what are the r and the f what do those
stand for
the r is this general carson r from
which all these are derived
and then the f's exit stand for first
elliptic into the first kind except so
roughly being the f
is first electric integral k is the
complete elliptic integral etcetera so
they are related to the current elliptic
integrals but they are
definite and not indefinite integrals
and they are symmetric so you got two
parameters x and y or three
and they are symmetric in those
parameters
and we really need all of these guys as
separate functions
i mean well look given that we've got
jacobi cn jacobi
whatever i don't think it's cognitively
difficult to have
a lot of these functions it's just kind
of weird yeah
i think that actually even more in dlmf
so there are 10 and we picked eight
which looked like they were not
run in any way so but we need them
because they are going to be output from
integrals
eventually and it'd be nice to have
clean names for them for each separate
one
all right
um
okay
it's it's basically kind of like a bug
fix to correct
asymptotics or better asymptotics
okay okay all right let's get into some
detail
okay well where i mean just get me
some scope for this design yeah so there
is um
let me just yeah so let's talk about the
algebra there's a couple of very
exciting things there
um so
for for optimization symbolic
optimization
the two things one is to do what's
called parametric optimization and
that's when you have parameters
in addition to the decision variables
yes
we could already compute some of that
using cylindrical
algebraic decomposition right but we
have now
a new method that allows you to give
both better result
and and really scale to solve fairly big
problems
this will go directly into something i'd
hoped for this release but it will make
it for 13
which is something called model it will
be used many applications but here's one
it's called model predictive control
it's a fancy modern advanced control
design scheme
so we'll talk more about that in the
future so this is this is already going
in there
the second big thing for optimization
is pretty amazing which is that
we are able to solve everything that we
can solve
in convex optimization exactly
well okay which you can also do for a
linear
um you know linear programming can also
be done
exactly if it can be done right if the
simplex method can do it you can that's
correct
now there are of course some barriers
you know because of scale
because the numeric case can still go up
higher
but part of what we needed to do without
going too much into the details
is that it at the optimum because for
convex problems we know the dual
variables
you know the lambda and the mu variables
for the dual problems
yeah that means that we also know
what are the binding constraints or
what's called the active constraints the
ones that are
equalities equations
my question is what what i mean when you
go to the corners
in a piece of convex optimization you
know when you go to the corners
in in linear optimization you're just
going to get rational numbers
yeah you go to the corners in convex
optimization what do you get you get
algebraic numbers or what do you get
yeah whatever is in the problem so it
might be worse than algebraic numbers
they're transcendental numbers often
but we can represent them symbolically
yes so the big innovation here what we
needed to represent
is the symbolic solution of a system
a system route yes okay
and so since we know where they are we
can verify that this is a unique
it is a unique route that's what we know
from convex it's the unique global thing
and it's a unique route we can now
validate that
independently once we have a good enough
approximation to it
that means that we can raise the
precision to infinite precision from
finite precision
i see so you have a way of describing
a root for a system of equations
that's right you can describe a specific
route
by some indices and you can validate
that those indices
are sufficient that's right what happens
if it's a non-trivial algebraic variety
that is the solution
so there are cases where when you have
multiple multiplicity
um that we that it may not work
um for algebraic varieties we
in principle could always figure that
out for for
analytic or locally analytic varieties
um it's a little bit more dicey
so actually i think it's root new to
test the updated
okay all right
yeah this one has a little bit more work
to be done on it because we're going to
build
illustrations there and things they're
not
they're just prototypes or things i see
what is the root ordering method
there is there is an old root ordering
method that was introduced in version
three of mathematica
and it sorts them and so you can use an
integer index to indicate which root
yes but that only works in that works in
the complex plane yes
that works when you have only finitely
many and you know globally all of them
it doesn't work so well when they're
infinitely many and you don't know
globally all of them
i mean it cannot work then it's just the
idea is not good
okay enough what's the approach so then
the other approach we we use
an um a neighborhood
of the route that guarantees that there
is only one route
route in that neighborhood
it's it's a multi-precision number with
with uh
where the precision tells you the radius
of the ball
so it's a ball yes in the complex plane
yes so in general it can be multiple
complex numbers so it's a it's a it's a
ball
in the n-dimensional complex space yes
okay
and precision doesn't necessarily
actually strictly speaking i think it's
a polydisc
it's like precision doesn't mess you up
at zero
but then yes then it has to use accuracy
so but we haven't really described all
that yet
there we we need we have more iterations
to be done on this
i'm sorry about that that it just got
delayed okay
all right but basically the description
is
which one is it here near x equals c
yes that's the second one
okay
i see okay how does it i see and it
knows how many variables there are
this just counts the number of equations
yes
and it's always the number of equations
equals the number of variables in all
cases
yes okay
what design is are there in this section
this there's none really
i mean there is the new thing that was
you you actually asked for it which is
soul values and end soul values
which you we had some discussion over
email over the
weekend just briefly and that's just
basically it's it's it's they're more or
less the same functions but they have
different output structure
yes to simplify workflows like for
plotting and
and other direct uses of
what happens if it only has one
so it's always going to give a list is
that correct yes
so if i say solve values
of ax plus one equals zero oops
oops that wasn't what i meant
i see okay and and it's pretty obvious
what can do if i were to say
this is what seoul does it
when it tries to parameterize when it
parameterizes the solution
it uses one of the sole variables
parameter
like x in this case
okay so with a single variable
these inner things are just singletons
okay makes sense
okay and then solve values does the
obvious thing right
so one more thing introduced here now
because we have these systems by the way
is to um just to to be able to solve
them
transcendental systems of equations in a
box
okay so behind the scenes this is using
a new
new type of interval methods and so on
but it was the machinery that we
developed for this
other optimization case that it caused
us to
get through so wait a minute so this is
what i should look at yeah
yeah this is um
these are really nice these
multi-parametric
linear and quadratic programming
so men value
hope there's a simple example this
yeah you can make it as simple as you
want
they still need to be sort of linear and
quadratic programming
or something transformable to those
classes
right
okay cool
this is not this can be done much
simpler i just ran a
time here is a much simpler way to
formulate this
but basically everything come back oh
yeah so listen listen i want to talk
about these things
okay i want to talk about how you use
these
how do i get out the the minimal
polynomial for example
first okay i'd never know that
i'd never know that not a million years
okay
we will describe this in the new root
object
okay but that's not it's not just a
description i i think
in modern times i mean so what else can
you get out of here
the numerical value i understand how to
get that that i'm not
confused about mm-hmm um
so if i but it's more than a millimole
polynomial it's it's a function
it's generally a function sometimes it's
a polynomial but
now you get out a function but it isn't
just a function it's full of crap here
right so that's not just a function
well it's a system and it's
approximation yes yeah
right which is different thing
so i'm going to come back to my same
question i want to get out of here
just i mean i understand it has all this
stuff packaged in it i'm i'm just saying
we need some kind of accessor and we
probably need
uh you know some kind of raft or
autocomplete or something
that allows you to just extract the
thing you need out of this
yeah like maybe it's the minimum
polynomial but i don't even know whether
that's
you know it's this i mean we can easily
support a bunch of properties
for it for instance what happened here
why is that reddening up
what what the heck
maybe it's just some bug in the
prototype build i don't know
oh yeah what
i'm still confused it's very confused
what
well something is very wrong here
oh oh oh look at that they're two
separate functions
it's not a oh you put the bra okay so
there was a there was a vector of two
functions yeah well
fine so you know i made my points here
yeah it's a mess right
you've got to be able to have a better
way to get these things out
okay we'll fix that what does this
say not normal
it's it is normal or ready okay so it's
going to do nothing
yeah input form will display the input
form
great and all its incomprehensibility
right right we need some way to access
things from here and we need it to be
visible in this mouse over in a more
useful way than this is
and by the way if you're gonna do a
prettified mouse over
then you should just put x's and y's in
there for that
first you know thing rather than the
hash business
yeah i mean this is not right this isn't
right what what
what you have for the mouse over and
things there
um the results are impressive though
yeah this is the transcendental system
in a box
it's impressive
i mean i guess if i say here
lovely there's something that bothers me
about these maybe it's a graphic design
issue maybe these numbers just shouldn't
be in
in encode font maybe they should be in
in um uh text font i think that would
help
because i tend to agree with you the
thing is
that this makes me feel like i can get
that number out somehow
whereas that number is just a label
do you see what i'm saying yes
why don't we ask design but i would
suggest just changing that to text font
yeah because because you know the things
drive me crazy it's like i want to pick
that number up
copy it do something with it but i can't
i do feel like you know on hover
there should be some kind of raft that
gives some options you know
when you say raft i'm thinking of
something that floats in a river
yes that's what i'm talking about i'm
talking about this this is let me show
you an example of our
that's a raft raft whatever you call it
that thing there that floats underneath
it
that's a raft okay we're calling that a
raft as a that's a
that's our ux name for it okay
because it floats you know it's a it's a
kind of a
a uh uh you know it it helps the user
it's like a lifeboat type thingy but it
floats
that's why we called it that i'm
surprised you haven't heard that term
before
i've heard it but jeff never sure what
it means because
it we did make it up ourselves it's a
floating ux element
okay it's a floating assistive ux
element
okay and i'm suggesting a raft here
rather than that tool tip which is not
very useful i'm suggesting a raft
this raft actually does something you
know it can go go pick that up
right what would this raft do
i think it might give you some options
for what you can pick up from that thing
i'm not sure it requires thought okay
requires knowing what you can do with
this i mean one thing is giving the
numerical approximation
another is um you know give me the
minimum polynomial
i i don't know exactly what
yeah i mean we were talking about sort
of having a
a click so these need to be smaller than
our big summary boxes which are
massive and you typically only have one
per line
but here they will be in internalized
lots of them yes i know
i know i think it's fine i think it will
help a lot to change that to text font
because that will look more like our
entities where you're not expected
it's not like you can pick it up and
copy it right
okay let's keep going
find instance wow that's pretty that's
pretty school
that's pretty seriously cool
yeah i mean i assume that what is what
is the um
for example what is the sorting
guarantee for these guys
sorting guarantee can i sort them
yeah and if for example
if i say okay
so let's do this let's say uh
integer part yes
pretty nice if i say fractional part
i'll get some presumably
yeah pretty nice okay
and so what about canonicalization it is
canonical
so equals equals will work okay
um yes i mean but it won't do
it depends on what you mean by works
um equal equals work
if they are the same within numerical
no they don't sorry no
yeah because in general your bounding
box two
no no it's not it's not like approximate
number these are exact numbers so it's
not
um no no i'm aware of that but my point
is their representation
their bounding rectangle or whatever
might they might represent the same
numbers
clearly there are multiple ways by the
time you're in the transcendental domain
it's undecidable whether two things are
equal right
yeah but but if they satisfy the same
equation and you have
balls that are let's see if you have
balls that are
yeah if one ball is included in the
other
then you know both of them guarantee
there's only one route
then they have to be the same
okay but
i think there's a little bit more to say
about this because i mean you can
clearly have two different
representations you can have
representations with zero
or is that will you detect that
by the numerical evaluation an ornate
definition of zero in terms of you know
nested trigonometric functions
that might be difficult to prove is zero
you might still detect is zero
or not um
no i didn't i don't think this can solve
the general zero equivalence
well it can't because it's undecidable
general zero equivalence for
trigonometric functions is undecidable
so you know uh no you need absolute
value as well for that to be undecided
um are you sure yes that you can't do it
with trigonometric functions alone
no no for trade now now trigger loan
it's it's not you need something else
like
absolute value is usually what's okay
well
okay but but but in any case in
but i mean i can clearly give so can you
deal with absolute value in these
transcendental route objects
yes okay so i mean but
you might be able to break out of the
undecidability
by just doing numerical evaluation yeah
for many things but i
in practice for most things it's not an
issue
but will there be boundary k there will
be boundary case
so i'm asking you again in double equals
the um uh
you know what are we doing with double
equals in cases where
is it going to return false incorrectly
in certain cases
no i don't think so okay
um someone
someone comes back to anyone anymore
okay all right let's keep going
uh construct a system of
root objects what does this mean
uh what not this is what we spent a lot
of time talking about already
okay this is something this is slightly
different
this is more domain knowledge about the
lipstick it seems like adam's stuff
maybe we should wait until adam is here
yeah
okay let's go talk about
um i did we have a permanent before
yes yes we had a test this is an
improved
performance performance
but what's the default method
because that's all we care about yeah
the default method yeah is the one
right on uh the third one yeah but
that's no
well i mean but no why why okay
okay come on you know we got to be able
to figure out when should we be using
these methods
okay because that's what that's what
makes the method valuable to us is when
it get
gets used by default not when oh i agree
with the documentation
and somebody told me about it you know
once you have no argument for me okay
this
is dan's work if we want to oh yeah then
get him here
this is what we need for these meetings
i mean
the i we shouldn't have brought this up
here
okay which who's qrd composition
that's danny as danny as well yeah okay
all right let's go on to the next item
and we'll wait
for adam and danny to get here otherwise
we'll loop back and talk about their
items in another meeting
okay bilateral laplace transforms right
what is that
that's just the fourier transform
explained to the full complex plane
so it's the unilateral laplace transform
extended to the negative uh real axis
exactly
yeah okay listen listen i've told you
this like 75
times why is that if still in that
stupid font
come on let's let's get it here too so
we can have this hash this out here for
sure
okay
that's not staying like that why is it
still like that in this version i
thought we agreed to fix it
okay what can we look at that isn't
what we're asking for this has nothing
to do with this review
the the the the typeset font there
okay but we'll discuss it we'll cover it
yeah we need to cover
this is bilateral laplace transform okay
and why is it in a box because it's a
conditional expression
right okay i think it should be a gray
box not a black box but anyway
black box has sort of bad connotations
right yeah
um okay i don't really understand what
this thing is so maybe i should just run
a particular
i mean if i just say uh one over t
squared or something oh
i just heard a singularity at zero so i
guess that's that's the problem
so it took a very long time to decide it
couldn't do that
right this course goes to integrate
because requires generate conditions
i mean the best one that will work are
always the
bounded uh support making a unit
triangle
that should be right why is this so
unbelievably slow
because reliance integrate and if we
need the conditions if we didn't we'd
have some
special method maybe but it we do
require the conditions away and
integrate unfortunately very slow for
them
i'm going to ask my question again in a
very elementary case like this
why is there not tons of stuff we can
cache to make this not so slow
we could do some table lookup yes we
could do that
seems useful to me because this is
pretty dead in the water
yeah right
boy we got some modern people on our
live stream somebody's asking can you
get that colorful graph as an
ft yes i'm thinking
as a non-fungible token
yeah as like a crypto kitty
it's become the craze the last few weeks
and we're actually in a very good
position to support those things
so that was it
yeah that's an interesting request
um okay so
i'm a bit disappointed it's so slow
is there anything for which it's not
slow uh
unfortunately the direct one is it's not
so slow if you got things like which are
piecewise which
seems a bit faster if you've got a piece
while like you know
which uh oh oh it's got only a half no
but why is this
i mean like if that instead of k there
was a one for instance there's no
parameters
shouldn't be a problem right yes i
said that we need the conditional
expression that the problem with the
table lookup v
in a special method you condition a
little bit hard so basically we have to
rewrite integrate for this case
so yeah this is really pretty awful
if real part of s equals zero what about
if real part of s isn't zero
well this one relies on the current
legacy integrates
that will be replaced eventually but
that's what we have right now
so what are we achieving with this uh
it's been requested many times by
the last couple of years by people from
signal processing basically
and they want us to because it they want
the conditions and they want us to
on the on the inverse they want the unit
step to show up
so when you do the inverse of a by
laplace transform you get
so uh the inverse bilateral laplace
transform
well well if you do let's say the hard
part over there so let's first example
right you have
a rational function okay okay sorry oh
sorry yeah that's a bug
i just know that yeah
so if you do a rational function okay
and you do the inverse by laplace
transform
then that's the case that interests them
they want
us to be able to do that correctly with
the
you know the strip of confidence yeah
okay yeah
right well i'm not impressed in terms of
speed but
i don't think there's much we can do a
little bit but not much in this release
and speed
long term the new integrate will solve a
lot of it yeah so the first example took
point four second five point two now
takes 17 seconds with the same integrate
same example so we lost 45 percent
45 times sorry anyway but we lost it for
what reason
yeah well for what reason well because i
i didn't maintain but it's just that
people have been maintaining it and it's
just had so many bug fixes over the
years thousands of them
that now it needs to be just replaced
basically so
which thing are we talking about here so
so so things like you know particularly
when you got
the full real interval then integrate
has a rough time because it needs to do
the
two separately and then combine them
that's where it gets in trouble it's not
so bad in the laplace
transform itself the bilateral is
on the whole real line that's what
causes problems for it
okay well it's a bit unimpressive
and i think it should it could do with a
bit of profiling before you wait to the
internet future
for replacing everything yes yes no i
think we
certainly make some improvements for
sure okay look i have a procedural point
which is that
can we please make sure i know we have a
lot of these design reviews coming up
roger
um either let's please make sure that
everybody whose functions is being
talked about
i mean you wanted to drill in more
and you you go on tangents and that's
going to require
many more people well they should be on
call anybody whose function is being
discussed should be on call i think
that's fair
that's reasonable but okay okay i'm here
i apparently was requested you were
why is this still in the ugly font
because i'm waiting for whatever other
updates uh design gets me and putting
them in all at once
okay fine and uh who is who is working
on that
billy and he he he gave he
he's i got an email from him a couple of
hours ago that he has something for me
to look at but i have not had a chance
to look at it
all right okay fine all right okay but
so we we had agreed that this we had
agreed on what this roughly was going to
look like right
yeah i think so right that you you
wanted a slightly lighter
uh well
code font that's right yes and i
i don't i don't know which particular
right we have more than one text font
right so i don't know which
okay fine but he's dealing with that
he's dealing with it and this frame
should be lighter
and other than that that's that's the
basic story here
yes but this is the most important thing
that this is i mean this is reading like
code and it's not
code okay okay and like
you know you reported that and like i
said i'm just waiting on the final spec
from
design instead of putting in a half
measure that's fine that's fine
i mean if if that isn't done by the time
of the design
design ux meeting at the end of this
week then please complain
okay okay all right was there anything
else
i hear no i mean the root object is
going to be for him too but
do you want to go there well the root
object is a that's a whole story about
putting
rafts on route objects but i think you
guys should talk about functionality
before we have a conversation about
look okay okay
thank you itai okay okay
okay let's keep going down here
there's no design change this is new
capability
it means that linear equations with
uh basically rational functions of trigs
and hyperbolics and exponentials
this is using the differential root yes
yeah it doesn't have to if it's low
order it doesn't necessarily use
differential root you know i got to tell
you something guys
then we should bring in itai again if
you want to have that discussion
okay look look look in this case it
doesn't do anything when you click
in the other case it does something i
know i have had the same discussion with
itai
okay then why don't we well
and well and it's i mean there's there
there's a reason for that
i mean right the the the difference is
that the size of a typical differential
root object is much larger than the size
of a typical
uh all right the problem is the problem
and i don't want to get into this in
great detail here because we've got some
other things to look at here
the basic problem is that i for example
got just really you know it's like
how do i get this data out i can see it
here
you selected it you select it and you
copy it
from this from here yes oh my god i had
no idea that worked
okay well why why would you expect it
not to work
i mean it's
okay but then why don't we make this not
a tooltip as well but if we had this be
the same behavior
where look presumably this had a hover
which says click for more info you know
i think that hover could just
light up this d thing because i think
that will make it clear that you can
click it
without having to have the the ugly i
think that's a really good idea actually
right and then then you click it you get
this thing
and this type of pane is not one from
which i would have expected to be able
to copy because it looks too much like a
tooltip
you said what i'm saying right and then
there there's all right oh well uh
i mean i didn't figure that out so just
to be clear
you know you might just accuse me of
being really dumb about this but i
didn't figure that out
okay so let me uh right so this is
another thing that
billy is currently looking at and
um i mean i can put the
his mock-up in the chat if you want sure
please
do that um all right
yeah i think all of these things okay so
first point is
this should not be in in in
code font this should be in some kind of
text d
font or mathy font or traditional form
font or something
this thing here because it it gives one
the idea you can copy it which you can't
and so this will then light up you press
it you get something here which is more
of a form where you can readily see
that this is like a sub notebook where
you can readily you know with white
background or whatever
but you can just copy things and and i
think these should also have
you know let me make the comment i think
this should have a click to copy type
um uh you know this should have
the you know copy iconography
um so each thing
should have a button possibly but i'm
i'm not sure well on on mouse over it
should have click to copy
but the other possibilities well i i
don't know i don't know that it
should right i mean what if you only
want to copy out part of it
part of this yeah well that's not an
unreasonable possibility i agree
what about the the possibility of
copying everything into a multi-cellular
you know input
that would be kind of weird right i mean
you could achieve more
more or less the same thing actually
what you really want is a list
that's what you really want you really
want to copy this out as a list
because that's what you want to feed
into our solve or whatever
that was the thing that was driving me
absolutely up the frigging wall
with um
what the heck are they called um the
things that give you recurrences
the things where you have a um fine
linear recurrence
no no no no different route difference
route yes difference route
what's driving me crazy i want to get
the stuff out of a different route
that i can feed into another function
how do i do it
answer i want this stuff as a list okay
if i go here
and i can copy the whole list right that
will be very convenient in fact
i don't really understand why this is
showing up not as a list here
i mean to me something formatted as a
list
whether perhaps on different lines just
for readability
would be the best thing
that making sense because that's what i
want most of the time is the list
most of the time you will get the same
object back when you feed it to our
silver diesel
well fair enough but i want to do things
with it you know i want to
i want i don't know what i want to do
with it but you know i want to do
something with it
okay you know i want to
go ahead sorry i uh i was having trouble
finding the chat button i'm
managing too many windows on screen but
there i just put
billy's mock-up on
okay
well i i don't like
large and bold but but that's okay
that's good to distinguish this but then
i don't think this is the right form
um and uh
yeah okay
pop out copy all what does popout do
i'm not sure i oh maybe maybe it's
copying that
grid into an input cell which i'm not
sure would be particularly useful
but maybe this is going to require
further design
review all right all right so i'll i'll
just add it to the
well if we'll have time i'll try to add
this to the lcc meeting
fine but then what we need is all forms
of box
like this please together and we need
that behavior to be consistent
between the algebraic root one
differential root difference root etc
okay okay i mean well up to a point i
mean
i i agree that algebraic number and and
root should be pretty much the same
and that root that differential root and
difference root should be pretty much
the same i'm not sure
right right that's the review i i think
they should be very similar
but but you know whatever
yeah i mean just right one is a
representation of a number and the other
the uh
one group is a representation of a
number and the other is a representation
of a function
i mean they i understand and that's the
difference but but but the difference
the fact that one is a function and one
is a number should not be manifest and
one being a tooltip and one being a
you know a pop out no yes i agree with i
think that
we are at this point now where we can
have this discussion
before we were just annoyed when they
came out now there are small
nice we want to tune it a little bit so
that workforce post workflows are
yes all right and billy also needs to
remember to
design what they look like before you
click okay let's quickly go through the
other stuff and then i
thought you're welcome to stick around
for a couple minutes but what is it
this is that's an old new function
i think we introduced it sometime eight
or nine or something like that but
anyways what this does it solves
systems of differential equations with
rational function coefficients
and it's complete it can solve every
such system
in terms of how exotic functions well it
will eventually need differential route
yes because you know ultimately what it
does is triangulate the system
to you know so you get a single ode
um you solve that you back substitute
and you get two
uh other ones one day it will be lovely
to have some kind of essay about what
the heck the point
we will
okay you will have a lot more useful
information
i think that the information in an
appendix style was a little bit on the
church side
indeed that was 30 years ago though yeah
but it's still there
i know
okay inactive operators so there's uh
oliver's stuff
but now working desold basically
so this is this is um
the the operators introduced by oliver
you know for modeling of pdes we often
use them in an
active form
and so they are now being parsed and
correctly interpreted
in the symbolic dissolve as well as an n
diesel
doesn't mean we can solve all of it at
all it means that
in the cases where it can be solved it
it will
okay so in other words if i put in a sim
simple
heat conduction equation thing of the
kind that
you know actual humans are expected to
solve you should be able to do it here
yeah yeah exactly i wish we had units in
these
in time yes
um okay so what is this
what are you what are you showing here
some random
numbers that's a solution i can see that
but why does d
cell value have 3.14 why is it not pi
because it's because the input seems to
have approximate numbers in it to begin
with
yeah so why is this different from what
oliver was showing before
what's the symbolic part of it it's the
formula
oh i see i see so there's an
undetermined coefficient here
there's a constant of integration yeah
but but also
oliver's way of solving is called finite
element it uses a completely different
scheme of solving
it doesn't get you i understand it
doesn't give you a new it doesn't give
you any symbolic results i realized that
yes yes
although this particular symbolic result
involves an undetermined coefficient
yes it has an infinite sum yeah
oh that was a sum i think yeah it's an
inactive sum yes basically
but so i could use this if i wanted to
and if i took that thing yeah and maybe
you did that already but if i took that
thing it looks rather ugly there
um in traditional form um i don't know
why it's in traditional form but
but i mean so if i if i recompute this
um so i i just like to change that
to a i'm going to take that to the x
equals 1
and i'm going to take that to be y
equals 2.
for no particularly good reason okay so
then i have
so now boundary conditions
and i solve this right it might take a
bit of time so it's a hard equation to
solve
that's well that solved immediately but
i i don't want to do any choppery
no chopping no chopping no traditional
form
no i just want i'm no no sleight of hand
here
the the capital t bothers me
okay what happened there well it's
returned immediately unable to solve the
problem for some reason
does that uh i should note that it
should have got
uh t x y what why
why did it well i could send this to but
i mean why what what's capital t
it's oh that's what you're solving for
oh there's the independent variable oh
sandra is pointing out the rectangle has
to be bigger
outside that right
okay all right so let's go down here so
let's reevaluate all this stuff
um and we need to get the conditions on
the boundary of the rectangle so
the rectangle has to kind of match the
boundary conditions
how ugly i mean in other words
it's annoying that that would be
something
where you couldn't explicitly ask for
the boundary of this object
in other words are you giving the
boundary okay can somebody tell me what
the boundary condition should be
so so so your dirichlet condition uh
has to be on this same level
so x equals is this i forget rectangle
goes from x y so that's
equals like this right y equals one
there right yeah
and now we've got a neumann condition at
y equals
yeah zero not start compute sorry so we
need to have it the the delicious
conditions given exactly to for for the
problem to be well posed
otherwise they don't have a well posed
problem and this is uh i mean it's
pretty hard it has to do some
integration but it should finish up
and you should might get somebody okay
so the next my next comment is
i would love to have a status a progress
indicator yeah
okay what would it be we're getting to
that we haven't really introduced them
yet
in symbolic computation but we're
gearing up to introduce them in
in many places actually okay that was
pretty impressive
now so if i take that function
and i say let's say uh 0.5 0.4.5
hello why didn't that evaluate because
it's an inactive sum
so now you need yeah if you activate the
problem it's going to try a symbolic
evaluation which has not been very
successful
so you need to finish some to get
something useful out of it
i mean these sums are essentially
impossible to evaluate symbolically
they are formal results and you need to
replace infinity by something to get
a meaningful result you know right we
need some functions that do that
well why did this produce an active
results well there was nothing inactive
in the input
because if you don't do that then you
get back i know i know but how do
no we really we really want to do that
we want to produce inactive integrals
and inactive sums
but i agree with you steven we need a
workflow that makes it easy to
right to get
get sort of finite results under some
level of control yes
right i mean to me this is the wrong
name these saw value if you're trying to
get an inactivated result
there should be something in the d cell
value that says
give me an inactivated result otherwise
i know
if we don't do that steven we will be
the slowest system on the planet
yes guaranteed guaranteed
for no good reason just self-inflicted
wounds for no good reason
just completely self-inflicted right and
stephen i mean stephen
and steven right well people right when
they're solving pd's right they do
expect to see the sum of the projection
onto the eigen system on
under the eigenvalues i know so
i don't think it's consistent though
because there are other cases with these
cell value
where it does not give inactive results
where it just gives the final result
right but that's also judgment called
eventually but that that's when it
there's a closed form right
i think that we could perhaps have a an
option that controls that
and the default setting should be
automatic that's fine but then you could
insist on it evaluating if you're
if you're one of those that's fine okay
and that's fine
wait um that's fine now in this case
here
the problem is you've got an active sum
but there's no way to reach in other
than me editing that infinity
which would be really weird there's no
way for me to reach in
and i mean i'm surprised that this isn't
giving me some approximation
i mean doesn't end some isn't it
perfectly well able to deal with
infinite sums
yeah enzyme is not we've tried okay
we've try to replace the sum with n sum
it's not so good i mean in terms of
quality of results
um because n sum doesn't know much about
oscillatory sums that that's the i mean
we just tried last week actually to see
whether we could use
n sum instead of replacing the interval
and sum is using you know
uh extrapolation techniques right to
figure out what the what the sum is
doing
right and if the thing is oscillating
like crazy that's probably not gonna i
mean
depends how you do that i mean if it's
doing some fourier analysis
of the some and maybe it can do it yeah
but if we're going to have lots of
oscillatory sums that we really care
about we probably should be doing that
all right so what what again what is it
doing
right now it's trying to compute the
exact i know i understand that why is it
taking
it i mean what what what what could be
because summation is undecidable
because it's very hard what is it trying
to do what is it what is it doing
right so so it's an infinite sum it's
going to try and
a few things it's going to first try the
algorithm for trigonometry
summation then it's going to try and do
an expansion it's going to try and do
some q rational summation
convergence testing so it's going to try
the whole battery of
a large battery of infinite sum method
where there's no hope of getting a
solution at the start itself
okay but so so the basic point is you
can't even tell me the first digit
of this of the answer is that correct i
mean that's really hard to know
because it's an oscillatory function
right correct
okay so for example i'm i'm gonna i'm
gonna
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna test whether
you're whether you're
right there okay so that's this function
i replace k1 with
x and you know what i'm going to do here
why did that not work
okay so now let's say plot this
x goes from 0 to 20 let's say
maybe you need a re-implant or oh
do i need a re-implant i don't think so
not for this one though
yeah i am then then i'm a bit surprised
why we're not actually seeing anything
yep apparently you do okay good good
okay
so the claim is this isn't a solitary
function and you seem to be correct
about that
yes what a mess
yeah but this is the laplace it's called
a combination of hyperbolics and
trigs so one of them will come from the
let's say the x and they all come from
you know the y so
okay but so in the infinite sum we're
going off to x equals infinity i don't
see much contribution from are you
saying
that all that center stuff cancels out
how am i left out with the
yes that's the whole point that that on
their own each sum is not
each term is not that meaningful but
when you combine them then you get that
nice cancellation and so at 40 terms
that's things here there's pretty
close to nd solve the the plot you see
down below that's from the any sort
documentation
uh the that one yeah that is exactly
what uh the
fem method will get you no i understand
but i'm asking the question
here yeah you are claiming the reason
you can't do the sum
is because there are tail contributions
that the center has cancelled out
and there are tail contributions that
can
you know mess you up is correct we are
not doing numerical summation if you're
doing numerical the tails matter when
you're doing symbolic you need to be
able to do the whole sum
and you can see that that you have a
combination of hyperbolics and trigs
there's no hope of those working inside
some that's the point
no i i understand that devendra if i try
to compute this
you know just numerically right yes this
is obviously a complicated messy thing
right it looks like it might be you know
it's there's a big contribution from
these guys here
right i can see that perfectly well
right right there's
no big contribution from these tales
here yes
right so my question is why isn't that
something that and
some is capable of dealing with it may
some that doesn't be end some that would
do it i mean
how unless you want us to return no no
no i i understand i understand but in
this case
this would be if i said some wouldn't
work
would not work i mean it should work
yeah well i would think it would work i
mean
was it from zero to infinity yes it was
from one to infinity
okay so let's just try n sum of that
okay so it's got a tiny complex part so
let's take
n sum as a function of x max
okay let's just plot that
x max goes from let's say 5 to 30 x max
xbox thank you
oh so yeah maybe in this case it might
actually yeah okay
so what happened uh i think you might
need to
no the problem is that or something oh
yeah
i don't know why that would complain
about that to be honest
we shouldn't
oh you know that this is kind of
crazified that the um
uh let's do this let's just make a table
of that right with xmax there
my gosh why is this taking forever what
is this doing
what on earth is this doing it
unfortunately enzo you might if it did
verify convince goes to false you might
be more lucky
i'm not looking for luck i'm looking for
no no i'm just saying that
then it won't do the convergence testing
and some otherwise it's going to take
time to convince testing as well
and by default it will have about 25
terms which will pick up to
do the approximation okay so if i take a
finite sum
why does it need convergence testing
yeah i mean here i could just use sum
actually exactly yeah
that's what we are doing effectively
that's exactly what we are doing
oh this is exciting i haven't seen this
new um
what the heck is that yeah
there's still an x and percent 47.
it's represents 47 not the thing oh wait
some we're summing over x
we have there oh let's i don't know
let's put that there then there won't be
any confusion
okay now look at what i see yes
look at that isn't that beautiful isn't
that i mean
if i say you know
okay that is not a difficult piece of
convergence
well it's yeah but keep in mind that i
don't
we we we have to use what's available so
if i call n sum
you can see i don't have any hope of
getting the good result quickly
in general so my best bet is to use a
finite sum like you're doing over here
that's exactly what we do when we
approximate
so when you when we plot things we first
replace infinity by some large
limit but not you by hand
we're talking about something that
automatically does that because in this
case
we can plainly see and you know a little
dash of machine learning would probably
help it even further
that this thing has you know this thing
is dead
it's flattened out right you don't you
know this was a really elementary thing
for me to do
to just take ten terms or something and
find out that it's
you know completely flattened out we
didn't need to waste a huge amount of
time we could have just computed those
10 terms compute
10 terms and 20 terms and see if they're
the same right so no i mean we couldn't
return that
from we couldn't return that from right
so
right you got it for 10 terms for a
particular value of x and y
absolutely absolutely but that what i'm
saying is
i don't understand why n sum in this
case
was just dead in the water
what is it doing why couldn't and some
figure this out
i don't know uh why don't you try
it again because maybe it was the same
variable issue
all right what's the same variable issue
maybe okay
let's try it so so n sum you're saying i
take this
so what i want to look at is n sum goes
up to infinity here
we're waiting right and he could try and
verify convince goes to false to like i
said that's what people do and they want
to speed things up because it's going to
do some convergence testing on its own
that might work i don't look after in
some but that would be my guess in that
sometime that helps
right it could also be the well
there there are issues with our n family
of functions
you know the the older ones so
um i think this one was trying to be too
clever for its own good
yeah that that does seem like it should
be able to handle it better
i mean it's such a smooth looking
function here
right this is um
well could somebody mute themselves if
they're
um
yeah look at that thing okay not you
gotta look at in some
and do some obvious things i think nsum
was just trying to be too
um you know
it's it's using some crazy algorithm
with extrapolation that it absolutely
doesn't need in this case
and where it can't prove extrapolation
and so what
yeah there's a look there's a whole
family of things that need to be done
for enzo
but we this is not the team
first of all no i understand but it's
it's
it's it's kind of torpedoing
your otherwise nice results here and
you're building a whole bunch of
you know crazy sort of hackery
around it to avoid the fact that that
isn't working i mean it should be the
case
if i just say n of this it just well i'm
not sure
well okay i agree that end of it should
work but
i mean i don't think we want to replace
that sum with n sum
no we don't we absolutely don't
look i think that having automatic for
the inactivation thing
makes sense for for diesel value and
then i think
you know figuring out how to make n of
that work properly
is the other other part of that story
when will we be able to do my favorite
non-linear
um what's your favorite
uh sander is asking we'll end some with
it infinity is still taking infinite
time
now that's the whole point i mean that's
you know n sum
is that's why n sum is doing clever
things it's trying to it's trying to
basically find a fit to the function
that allows it to transform the thing
so that it becomes a finite finitely
doable sum
where it's using some kind of um oh gosh
what is that formula the
the um version what's that
no no no no the formula that allows you
to replace
um plus on summation formula
for for replacing sums with integrals
and so on yeah
but with moylan we started a whole
program to update all these functions
but then he moved into marketing so
that's not moved since then
um the we have a whole there's a whole
range of things that
nsam doesn't know about and it's not
which we run into it's the same as the
old
and integrate but but new and integrate
is very capable
in comparison can you use some of the
same technology for ansum
kind of it's not as big an overlap as
you
as you think but one of the kinds of
methods that we really needed to use
more about these
convergence accelerators non-linear
convergence accelerators
yeah for sure i mean that's basically
transforming variables
yes but we need to allocate resources
okay what is this doing i'm gonna first
order pdes
it's it's
yeah so that's a complete integral uh
from d solve
sharp it's method is slightly more
systematic it does essentially the
method of characteristics for first
order pds
and it works this works in the case of
two variables and there's jacobi in the
jacobi in the case of three variables so
these are kind of improvements to
strengthen our nonlinear first
order pde solver
well fair enough except that i don't
know
okay explain the value of this given
that you can't actually solve the
general
number so so so for each
set of parameter values you have a
solution
then if you take a family of those you
can get envelope solutions which are you
know the limiting
uh case of any family like you got the
second
constant c to express the family of the
function of c one
then you get a you know an envelope
construction like a huygens construction
and that's another solution so
although it looks very simple this can
be used to build up a general solution
for the pde
so it's a constructive way of building
solutions for the pd
that's the way it's used in things but
the thing i don't understand is
you know i would think that you know
there are names like a general solution
a
a uh you know they're these different
named kinds of solutions right
non-linear pdes yes why can't i just ask
for one of those types of solutions why
isn't there a way of asking desolve
to give me you know the general solution
the
a special solution whatever else rather
than just you type it in and you get
some random solution that it happens to
be able to give
right because we i think the chance of
getting a general solution for knowledge
pd is almost zero
the linear case is very different we
essentially only have complete solutions
okay but where what are the named
incomplete solution so to speak aren't
there names for different types of
incomplete solutions well
well one can incompletely only have like
one solution which is
doesn't have any parameters in it those
are not good for us because that means
they can't reuse them anywhere else and
desolve
i mean there's just they're dead you
know these ones are the only family
which we have imprint because these are
kind of reliable they have
so what's the name for this family uh
complete integral
just it says find a complete integral
well that's what i thought right but
that's a
but that's why i'm saying there are
other ones too solitary wave solutions
well those are for not for first order
but mostly the kdb equations or
something but right but
the point i'm making is i would be much
more convinced if it says
find the the um complete integral
for this you know differential equation
then solve the equation where i know
it's just a shot in the dark because
most
non-linear pdes not in a
you know pdes are just hopeless right so
why don't we have a thing called
complete integral
that will compute that for a different
you know for a pde
and another one called you know i don't
know if it makes sense
to say soliton solution i'm not sure if
that's a well-defined thing
um well solitary wave are not solid
i mean they can build they build up
solitudes but fair enough okay right the
solitary wave is the
is the building block the tank or
something for the kdv
equation or whatever it is if i remember
right that's right yeah
the um so why don't we have that
you want new functions which do that
sorry do you want new yeah either that
or possibly a a um an argument to
desolve but i think new functions make
more sense
because you're signing up for something
you can actually deliver them rather
than
saying you know dsolve can do whatever
it feels like for a non-linear pde
it's not going to get very far with it
right so historically that's how
we did it uh in version three we had a
complete integral function inside a
package
which then got baked into dissolve
because it involved a package
okay well so then maybe we need to make
it its own function now
yeah it's powerful enough that it
actually makes sense i mean it's no good
having complete integral
and then it only works in two cases no
this one is
actually that's the whole point we have
tested on calm case been testing lots of
sources so
it's not pretty powerful in fact that's
the thing we didn't talk about the
monograph on pd's which
you know actually says exactly what we
have in this area and we have a lot
i did a lot of testing for version 6.0
actually and then since then we've been
doing a bit
but this is getting more complete now
with the sharpie and jacobi methods
so i think so so let's plan on a
function called
integral sure definitely done the um
i gather adam just trying i'm really
late for something else so i'm not sure
we're going to be able to cover this but
what was what was the question for adam
was zero recognition
for root objects uh uh so
they are never zero so they we try to
recognize zero
before we solve the equations so so no
coordinates of
of those two touches will will ever be
zero okay but what about equality
testing
in other words can i end up with two
root objects
which are in fact the same number but
which are sufficiently differently
presented that that equal
can't determine them to be equal yes of
course
we which is true for for for other
number representations that we already
have
we can have explicit representations of
x block numbers
that that are the same but we have to
show that they are equal
is that true for polynomials or only for
our more extended
for so for algebraic numbers it's
we we can in principle always decide
that whether they're equal if they are
algebraic numbers
written as root objects or radicals
if we go outside that like like we add x
blog or other elementary functions
already we cannot
prove that two things are equal right
it's not just our fault it just happens
it's basic it's does that hit
undecidability immediately with x-men
log
ah it may not be known
may not be known yeah right but i think
if we go too complex then we will be
able to
to encode a
uh diaphantin equations in terms of some
exploitation
i don't think you need complex i think
you just need triggs oh yeah
yeah actually we don't yeah we just need
triggs right we count
triggs and pi and we can encode integers
once we can call integers we can't code
the undecidable different
equations and then we can't tell whether
it's zero or not
right okay but but as a practical matter
okay so the question really is if i type
you know root object equals the equal
equal root object
there are then two cases three cases
three creases yes
we know they're not equal we know
they're equal
and we don't know either way yes okay
and you handle those three cases
yes so it's the standard evaluation of
equals so it tries numerically
then it tries some symbolic
transformation otherwise it comes back
on the evaluators okay fine
and and how common is it for one to end
up with the same algebraic number but it
is not recognizably the same
or the same you mean the same
non-algebraic number
right the algebraic no i'm sorry okay
the the same
transcendental root yes you you
i i don't think you you do it you know
it's not likely to happen
have you do you haven't by chance
not not ready one but but it's easy to
construct
if if you want to construct someone it's
pretty easy
just just take some take some functions
that are not obviously
uh the same but but they are
the same and and then the same route of
those functions
okay but so the point is there's no full
simplified that's being done
on the function in the first argument of
the root object
right and and even if there was it
wouldn't simplify not
only
right so there is actually full simplify
for
for for the for those root objects where
we try to
to call reduce and and get the explicit
solutions
but again it may or may not work fair
enough i mean that's life that that's
there's nothing we can do about that
it's just the way mathematics works
um okay i think that was the answer we
needed
um they uh
okay the question there's a question
here you need to know if a number is
algebraic
or does the program decide if the number
is algebraic well
within reason we decide but if you ask
whether pi to the e is algebraic i doubt
anybody knows
right um
or or or we cannot recognize zero
so zero in particular is algebraic
yeah what if square root of 2 to the
square of somebody asks about square
root of 2 to the square root of 2
because that one is known
what's the answer for that one uh i
believe the answer is yes
but it's algebraic or is it that it's no
i better i don't remember i'm trying to
remember i just remember
i i just remember this was related to
one of the hilbert problems that was
eventually solved yes
that's right i remember that too and and
so so the answer is known
uh i wonder if we know it
yeah adam how do i how do i ask for the
square
element algebraics if if it's if it's if
there is a criterion that
that will do this then or if we know
ever about one then it will work
oh it says false okay so it's okay so
right so
that must be transcendent yeah yeah so
that there is a
criteria that does that so we have some
some of the influences
right cool okay good stuff anything else
here
i need to run along all right thanks
guys thank you mr folks on the live
stream
see you another time